Louis Steve it's very nice to meet you
to bury so the first question I had for
you was about the table read process
because I had read that you hadn't fully
committed to the film before signing on
to actually do the table read so was
there anything about that process that
you were kind of looking out for to know
that this was the right project for you
know to be clear I was not invited to
Patricia to participate in the film yet
I've heard the judge was doing a movie
with Pete Davidson and I said to my
agents I didn't even know what it was
about I just said is there a part for me
because I love those guys and then when
I then when I found out what it was
about then I really wouldn't be in it
and but they didn't have a part for me
but they I was invited to the table read
well it was more than a table read they
had like an invited audience and later I
talked with Judd on the phone he said
well there was this character of papa
he's the senior guy in the firehouse he
doesn't--he others not a lot for him but
maybe you know but maybe we could add
some stuff and I said yes I'm in please
so that's how hard it's hard to imagine
that role going to anyone else right now
especially with all of your experience
as an actual fighter fighter firefighter
so just in general is there anything
about how firefighters are shown in this
movie that you don't think we see on
screen enough well I think just who they
are as people you know you know we tend
to you know it's only when they were in
the news or there's a big event and
certainly 9/11 you know I think people
did get to experience more you know who
they are but still you don't get to
experience them in their house like in
the firehouse
and that was an important thing for Judd
and Pete and the writers to show what
it's like when you're not out of fire to
show what it's like you know and to show
it like you know a little bit of your
home life you know firefight
people with and everything that means
you know they have issues they have
problems hunts and and yet when the time
comes to you know perform they band
together and they do it and and I think
Jed and Pete really show that in the in
the innate and a unique way
oh absolutely bringing up Joe is there
anything that you experienced being on
one of his sets that you plan to take on
to your own sets as a director well just
you know judge like any good director
I've worked with it's creating an
atmosphere on set where people not only
the actors but everybody can do their
best work and yeah I love that he you
know that he'd let us improvise so so
much and and he has rehearsals you know
and these things were important to him
and I think it should be important to
all directors and because I'm a very big
fan of tattoos and what they mean to
Pete and in this movie do you have any
tattoos yourself and if you don't what
would you get and why I don't have any
tattoos somebody asked me this earlier
like if I would allow the peach a tattoo
me what would that be and I think it
would be you know something that was
fire-department related you know yeah I
think I think that would be a nice thing
so maybe that will happen in Pete's
basement in Staten Island make sure you
share a picture of what the end result
looks like I'm curious now to wrap her
up here a little off topic if you had
the opportunity to revisit any of your
past roles who would you pick and why
boy that's a tough one but I like you
know see more from Ghost World somebody
said that it's does coming up on the
20th year anniversary of Ghost World and
I'm curious to see what Seymour's doing
I would be very into that but can I put
in a personal request for a visit to
airheads and bring in Rex back yeah
bringing the lone Ranger's perhaps
brings back a band
you know it does not sound like the
worst idea in the world I would wonder
weird they're where they're at so many
years later I love it who knows and any
any excuse to get back you know I'm set
with Adam Sandler well I'm all for oh I
totally don't blame you on that one
thank you so much for your time today I
really appreciate it and a huge
congratulations on the movie because I
think everything you said especially
about the the portions in the firehouse
are very very true more very powerful
thank you very angry [ __ ]